you could wake up in the morning and you
say you know what
today is gonna be a great day today i
expect something really good to happen
for me today
man thank you lord for waking me up this
morning he said what did you say
you said i said i'm having a great day
today i expect something good to happen
today
thank you lord for waking me up forming
positive turns around and goes
all right let me have your attention
steve's having a great day today
he's expecting some wonderful things to
happen and man let's get it going
and they start manufacturing thoughts
same brain
man i can't wait to go to work today it
may not be the job i want but at least i
got a job
i'm so grateful i got a car to drive to
work today
hey man at least i got a check coming in
i so want to thank you lord for this
roof over my head today
i appreciate the fact that i don't have
a car but at least i can walk to the
train
man this is going to be great today
that's how your mind works
24 7. it never turns off
you have got to change the way you think
it is the whole determining factor of
where you go in life
we are all where we are today because we
thought ourselves to this position if
you don't like the position
think yourself out of it change your
attitude
you change your altitude high performers
have that growth mindset where they
really believe
no i'm capable of becoming more
i'm capable of figuring it out i am
capable of busting through
i'm capable of getting the knowledge
skills and abilities that are necessary
for me to succeed
and that is a motivating driver for them
you have to be in that place where you
go you know what
i'm worthy of being around a players i'm
worthy of being paid well i am worthy of
achieving that next level i'm worthy of
an extraordinary experience in my life
because if you don't have worth you
could have all the gratitude in the
world
and you can still be emotionally broke i
am standing
for myself within myself
now take a breath
[Music]
i am standing for a new vision
now take a breath i am
standing for my divine purpose
now take a breath
[Music]
i am standing for my highest and
greatest good
now take a breath
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's do that again
i am standing for myself
within myself i am
balance
[Music]
i express balance
[Music]
repeat these words out loud with
conviction
with certainty with confidence
with passion and with power in your
voice
i am balance
i have balance
i am love i
have love
[Music]
i am motivated
to pursue the life of my dreams
i am powerful
beyond belief keep
repeating these words you can say them
over and over again
i am enough
i have always been enough
i will always be enough
i am enough and i always will be enough
i am lovable
i am worthy of love
and again i am lovable
i am worthy of love
i am so in balance
that i give love and i receive love
the more love i give the more love
i receive because i
am balance i give
and receive love i give
and receive praise especially
to myself
i give and receive compliments
i grow my own self-esteem with
love praise
and compliments
i am self-directed
i am purposeful
i am productive
i am blessed
i am grateful i am
worthy i am
healthy i am intuitive
i am smart i am
beautiful inside and out
i am magnetically attractive
i am brave
i am lovable i am
successful i am
warm i am empathic
i am deeply deeply lovable
just the way i am
i am peaceful i am
full of respect for myself
and others i am
self-respecting
i am evolved i am
sorted i am balanced
[Music]
i am equal to everyone
i am flexible i am
open i am present
[Music]
i am a person that matters
i am deeply significant
i am talented i am gifted
i am inspirational
i am positive i am
healthy i have a
generous heart a generous
nature i give
and i receive i
am wonderful i am
gorgeous i am so beautiful
i have a beautiful soul a beautiful
heart
a beautiful nature i am a gorgeous
person
i am curious i'm
always learning i am grateful
for my life just see love
just see possibility just see all the
things that you've come through
and then i want you to speak to yourself
as if you were your best friend
say your first name i would say lisa say
your first name
and then complete these three sentences
the first sentence
say your name first lisa i would say
lisa
i'm proud that you and find seven
different things to celebrate
yourself for and they can be small
things lisa i'm proud that you got out
of bed this morning
i'm proud that you i'm proud that you
pray today
i'm proud that you went to work today
i'm proud that you
set a healthy boundary in that
relationship i'm proud that you got out
of the relationship
i'm proud that you said yes even though
you're afraid
to leap about that new job i'm proud
that you
got on the phone today with your mother
whatever that small thing is that you
can celebrate they don't have to be big
huge things remember celebrate the micro
wins
and the micro wins become macro wins and
you say i forgive you for
go back 20 years go back 10 years go
back five years
or go back five days lisa i forgive you
for getting in a relationship
that wasn't worthy of you lisa
i forgive you for lowering your
integrity bar and saying yes when you
really should have said no
lisa i forgive you for endangering
jelani
when you got into an abusive
relationship unknowingly
lisa i forgive you for not getting out
sooner quicker faster
lisa i forgive you for gaining over 80
pounds
being too stubborn to go to the doctor
to find out what was really wrong
at least i forgive you for blaming
yourself
when a relationship didn't go right and
he left
when in fact man's rejection was really
god's protection
but she blamed you that second sentence
is liberating sobering
a little painful and definitely free
lisa
i commit to you that today i will only
say yes when i want to say yes
and i'll say no on the days that i need
to say no
lisa i commit to you that i won't keep
score
i won't collect evidence on why life
won't work for you
our relationships won't work for you or
this next eating plan
won't work for you i won't keep track i
mean i won't keep score
i won't collect evidence why it won't
work i'll keep track on why it should
work
lisa i commit to you that today
i'll stop the negative chatter sooner
quicker faster
and i'll go into the love chatter sooner
quicker faster
if you want some affirmations for
success from tony robbins check out the
video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there things are
impossible until somebody does it
and so uh i find that you know most of
your business people you look at
businesses and what does it take to make
a business grow it's not impossible like
a business grow business been shrinking
for a long time or